do not think a father figure is required
I think you can live you can be a good
[ __ ] person without a father figure
so why do you inherently need one
because me personally I'm big on family
my family supports each other around so
I'm saying support system I'm talking
about aunties uncles they all get
involved it's not just the fact it's not
just it's not just the father only that
still does my place of Father it doesn't
find the figure by it helps no the
support system is support it's not like
the actual helping you need like the
father is not there but you're being
supported by people around you okay so
it makes it easier for you yeah okay so
but that still doesn't replace having a
father in there it does he does either
so it is to be selfish if women choose
to not not to be able to have a father
and then go still going to have a child
that's inherently selfish and what Pearl
said all the statistically disadvantage
so if we look at especially if we look
at what's happening now in London a lot
of the live crime a lot of the stabbers
and what's going on look at who's doing
it and when you when you look at all the
kids that come from single parent homes
by the good support system so how about
that